cientos de Aldeanos sumergidos en las
turbias aguas de un lago del este de
Camboya cestas de bambú y redes en mano
celebran el final de La agotadora
cosecha de arroz pescando exactamente
como lo hacían sus antepasados
[Aplausos]
incluso conseguí pescar algunos con mis
propias manos sin trampa
[Música]
hacía dos años que no podíamos organizar
esta ceremonia estamos muy felices
un mes antes de la competición las
autoridades locales cierran el lago para
asegurarse de que la pesca será buena
ese día el gobernador provincial
Recuerda que para la competición sólo se
aplica una regla
se trata de pescar con métodos
tradicionales también es una forma de
recordar a los aldeanos y especialmente
a Los Pescadores que no deben utilizar
equipos ilegales
se refiere a la llamada pesca eléctrica
ilegal que consiste en enviar descargas
a los sedimentos para hacer subir a los
peces
en Camboya cerca del 40% de la población
depende de la pesca para vivir pero las
poblaciones de peces han disminuido en
los últimos años debido a la sobrepesca
y el aumento de los métodos de pesca
ilegales también por las presas
hidroeléctricas construidas en el país y
en las Naciones vecinas